معنا الان من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري صباح الخير وليد وليد مدى
وحجم الازمه التي تعيشها اسرائيل حاليا
نقراها
معك هذه الازمه تتعمق من يوم الى اخر
فبالاضافة
توتر متزايده من قبل نتنياهو ومقربيه مع
جهات امنيه وسياسيه ابرزها حاليا هو ان
انعدام الثقه المتعمق بين اوساط ذوي
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين في قطاع غزه الذين
لا يرون بان نتنياهو يضع مساله اعاده
ابنائهم واقربائهم على راس اولوياته ويضاف
الى ذلك ايضا التوتر بين نتنياهو وجهات
داخل مجلس الحرب الذي سيجتمع هذا اليوم
حول ما هي الاولويه هل تكون اعاده
المحتجزين ام مواصله هذه الحرب ونتنياهو
يريد مواصله الحرب لتحقيق ما يصفها
باهدافه والبؤره الاخرى التي يمكن ان يشار
اليها بهذا السياق هي مع المعارضه التي لا
تثق بتاتا بنتنياهو وهذا ما عكسته اقوال
يائير لبيد زعيم المارضه امس في الكنيست
عندما صعد الى المنصه وعقب والقى خطابه
بمناسبه مرور 75 عاما على تاسيس الكنيست
ردا على نتنياهو وهذا الاحتفال كما سخر
منهم والامر الاهم ان هناك اوساط في محيط
نتنياهو مثل النائبه في الكنيست جوتليب
وهي عضو ايضا في لجنه الخارجيه والامن
ومقرب من نتنياهو والتي هاجم
او كما قالوا بانها تفتري على جهاز المساد
وعلى جهاز الشباك لدرجه ان رئيس جهاز
الامن الشباك ايضا طالبها بالتراجع عن
اتهامات قادت اطلقتها هذا في مجمله من
توترات تشير الى ان الى جانب ما يجري في
قطاع غزه والذي يوصف بانه رغم تسجيل الجيش
الاسرائيلي تقدما كما يقول فوق الارض وتحت
الارض وتلقي ضربات قاسيه مثل ما جرى قبل
يومين بمقتل نحو واحد 24 من جنوده في بضع
ساعات في معارك متفرقه وتفجير مباني فانه
يعكس ايضا حاله التخبط داخل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الحاليه والابرز او في مجمل
هذه الامور مجتمعه هو الجميع الذين
نتنياهو قد وتر العلاقات معهم او خلق
صداما معهم جميعهم يرون بان هو يضع مصلحته
الاولى مصلحته الشخصيه الاولى السياسيه ام
قبل كل المصالح من خلال انه يسير نحو
تثبيت توليفته
الحكوميه للاستمرار في رئاسه الوزراء وانه
لا يخدم بذلك مصالح اسرائيليه وطنيه وفق
تعبيرهم لذلك مجمل هذه الامور لابد ان
وضعها في سياقها بالاضافه بطبيعه الحال
للتوتر المتصاعد داخل رئاسه هيئه اركان
الجيش حيث كان هيرسي هاليفي رئيس هيئه
اركان الجيش قد بعث بالامس برساله شديده
اللهجه الى مراقب مراقب الدوله الذي كان
قد اعلن قبل نحو اسبوعين عن نيته فتح فحص
كما سماه مع قياده الجيش حول الفشل الذريع
في السابع من اكتوبر وهو ما ذهبت جهات
امنيه داخل هيئه رئاسه الارك وجهات اخرى
الى اتهامه بالعمل لخدمه مصالح نتنياهو
وليس للتحقيق في مثل هذه الظروف لان الان
غير ملائمه حسب هيرتس هليفي ورسالته لان
الضباط منشغلون بالقتال وهذا سيصرف عن
مهمتهم الاولى وهو القتال في قطاع غزه
بالاضافه الى ذلك ذهب ايضا هيرتس هليفي
الى تجميد لجنه التحقيق الت الخارجيه التي
كان قد اعلن عنها وذلك الى حين انتهاء
اللجان الداخليه في الجيش من عمليات
التحقيق الداخليه والفحص الداخليه حول ما
يتعلق
بمساله الفشل الامني العسكري والاستخباري
في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي في غلاف غزه
هذه بؤر التوتر في التي تعصف بكافه دوائر
القرار في اسرائيل سواء كانت امنيه او
سياسيه جميعها تعكس حاله التخبط في هذه
الحكومه التي سيمها الكثير من
الاسرائيليين وذهب حتى ذوي المحتجزين في
غزه للمطالبه باسقاطه شكرا جزيلا لك من
رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري